uh death by scotland
so we are coming up towards the end of
series 10 and we've arrived at
an episode that i remembered very little
about
that's eaters of light and um
having not rewatched it i see why i
retained so little of it
it's not bad bad is usually more
memorable than this
it just is and it probably would be a
little bit less disappointing if it
wasn't
the last episode before the two-part
series finale and especially
knowing you know where things go later
and also
feeling like i will always feel like
this episode
or this series rather is at least one
episode
short uh which some ways it kind of is
show used to be 13 episodes long and by
this time it was just down to 12.
i don't think this is the first series
that did that but anyways
i really wish we had gotten a
full proper episode
out of what is going to end up being the
opening gag to the next episode the
whole thing with
missy you know trying to behave like the
doctor
monitored by him and i like i wish we
could have had a whole episode of
that and i would have put it here in
place of this
because again on its own
in a vacuum and had it come earlier in
the season
it'd be fine i think it's stronger than
knock knock if nothing else
but there just isn't all that much and
it doesn't
do a lot unfortunately to build towards
what we're gonna be getting i mean it
you should take it as a sign that for
however minutes i've already been
talking about i've barely talked about
this and instead of talked about
the series as a whole and what's coming
next there just
isn't a lot to this there's still some
neat moments and i think that's more
what i'm going to focus on than anything
else because the overall structure of
the thing
which is the doctor shows up there's an
alien threat there's two
um fighting factions who need to put
their own differences aside to fight the
threat
they fight the threat i mean that's
that's pretty much
it serves the purpose functional
not a lot extra going on um
i suppose the one thing that i will put
as a
a little bit of a legit criticism on
this uh as oppose
you know as opposed to just saying just
not that memorable is
that it has a theme running through it
that doesn't feel like it's been
properly worked into everything
um now i i have to decide in any given
episode of doctor who how much do the
thematics matter
how much were they intended to matter
and how well were they done because when
doctor who does
theming well you get
stuff that i adore and that includes
some episodes that other people don't
like nearly as much like
i still love can you hear me from series
12. i think it's
brilliant and it's brilliant because of
the theming but
that's the case where the theming was so
strong i was prepared to overlook what
some other people feel are flaws in that
story
now this doesn't have a core central
theme or at least not
one that it's actually built the entire
thing around properly it does
have one or at least it has one sitting
there that's not properly using
and that's overcoming fear and i know
that sounds like
well that's broad and generic and isn't
that usually what has to happen with
whoever the doctor is showing up to help
well yeah to some extent but in this
case you've got it on both sides
you've got the pics and the woman who is
the gatekeeper
who summoned this creature and
she has to overcome her own fear about
her place
in this society the role she is meant to
fill
her ability to fulfill it and also
the danger of what she might have
brought into the world
she's got a lot of fear directly related
to all that
and then you have the remnants of the
ninth legion and the only reason these
guys are still around as opposed to the
rest of the ninth legion that we saw
obliterated in a field is because they
ran away
so they are also having to overcome fear
in over to fight this in order to fight
this thing
so there you've got it there on both
sides
and had the notion of fear in general
and
overcoming fear in particular been more
core to the ideas i think this could
have been a lot stronger
heck the monster itself could have fed
into that
given that it relies on darkness and
drains away
light it's been noted in doctor who
before
people have an inherent fear of the dark
but that's also not really brought into
play it's like the pieces are here
to do something a lot more with the
thematics of what is presented
but either they needed another revision
to weave the themes into the whole thing
or the themes are there completely
accidentally
this sheer coincidence which
i want to give writers the benefit of
the doubt that they didn't accidentally
set up
stuff that would have been really good
and then just didn't notice that's what
they did
i'd like to give professional writers
more credit than that but
i have to grant that's possible
that would definitely be a shame if
that's what happened i hope it isn't but
in either case it is unfortunately not
fully developed into
the groundwork that's there but like i
said there's a lot of individual
elements and moments that i do
like quite a bit it's actually kind of
fun to realize
that bill hadn't come
to the knowledge up to this point that
the tardis translates
she didn't realize that and it was funny
for when it happened because i i'd
forgotten about this moment
it was funny when it happened because
then i'm like oh yeah
that's yeah and she even kind of herself
accounts for the fact that
maybe she should have realized this
sooner because she says that's why
everyone in space speaks english
what on earth are you talking about oh
my god it even does lipstick
which again like that's the kind of
observation that i love bill for this
sort of
little nitpicky observation that we as
fans are
aware of and often make but also know
we're supposed to overlook
and she's just like oh okay because like
logically if all the thing he's doing is
translating in your head then the lips
shouldn't match the words
because you're hearing english and
they're speaking latin it should it
should be like
dubbed movies but it's not and she notes
that and i think that's great
as weird and not again not integrated
into really anything as it is
i actually really like the crows i think
that's more my own
soft spot for
folklore and um sort of
celtic and fae and that whole um
you know region of uk british celtic
scottish uh irish all that mix of
folklore and i understand they're all
distinct i'm not lumping them together
but i'm saying that
collection and those kinds of
lore and fairy stories that tend to
exist
in those regions i really enjoy and this
thing with the crows the idea that first
of all all crows can talk
they're just really cross like it's a
toss offline from the doctor but
like that's just cute but then the idea
that they
are honoring that they are calling out a
specific name they're calling out carr
who is the the picked woman and
the idea that they are all honoring and
remembering her
just feels very folklore to me
and i like that as a vibe and
circling back to sort of uh bill noting
about the language first of all it's
actually a little bit of a callback
to um fires of pompeii you're speaking
latin
that's latin you just said that in latin
you're talking latin right now
seriously i just said seriously
as someone who really loves donna i
enjoyed that but also i
it's this is one of the bits that like
is well
interwoven and linked back to later
unlike unfortunately the overcoming fear
stuff which is just kind of there and
not done anything with
because we get this iteration
you know of bill noticing that for the
first time properly
and then we have the scene later where
the romans
and the pics finally understand each
other
for the first time they've never
actually properly understood each other
before
but now they do so now that we all
understand each other
how do we all sound you sound like
children
you sound like children too you all do
and just realizing
how silly things are at this point
and that's not to say that the conflict
at all is silly the pics certainly
have plenty of issue with the romans the
fact that the romans freaking invaded
and obviously at this point romans who
have lost their friends they're gonna
have some issues as well but
the situation they're in now where
there's a much bigger problem
and whatever has gone on between you
actually kind of in this moment
doesn't matter to just hear how silly
they sound to each other that's a good
moment
and that's sort of realizing the
importance
of the communication and just getting
everybody on the same page and on the
same level but again overall these
these little bits these little pieces
and even like little moments that i
like they're just kind of there
scattered about the monsters are
functional i mean we don't get a
particularly good look at them because
they're largely in the dark which is
a good idea uh given doctor who's budget
a lot of the time
and again i kind of like the folklore
feel of you know these
the this little band of pics and
romans fighting for what for them is
probably going to be
minutes but for us is going to be
centuries of time that they are
protecting us again that feels very
folklore and i do enjoy that
but it just doesn't all come together
and then there's the bit with missy at
the end which again
if they had properly identified the
overcoming of fear
as a central theme to this could have
tied back into this
but doesn't because we have this thing
with missy
you know basically saying i'm ready to
really try
and obviously the doctor's taking the
step of allowing her out of the vault
and the doctor has a line that i do
like that's the trouble with hope
it's hard to resist he recognizes
that this is potentially a really bad
idea
and instead of making it completely a
focus on his possibly false hopes
if they could have integrated the idea
of what he's afraid
of and whether or not he feels it's a
good idea
to overstep that fear again if they'd
made fear and overcoming fear as central
to the story as it could have been
this all could have come back to that
but it just
doesn't so again we have an isolation a
very good scene between
12 and missy because capaldi and gomez
have fantastic chemistry together and
are
always great whenever they're on screen
at the same time
but as an episode
it just kinda is
that was a thing that i watched
and now i've talked about and i'm out of
stuff
like i i only had like a half page of
notes on this
that's that's never a good sign eaters
of light
what did you think about it whatever
your thoughts are drop something down
the comments let's talk about it
i have a patreon which is what pays my
bills keeps this entire operation up
and running there's the usual stuff as
well like share subscribe but
no pressure you don't have to do any of
it
because at the end of the day you are
the council
and i'm just running the meetings so
until next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
um
bye